j'en fais avec moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il était vraiment plus âgés que moi je
suis tout bêtement compétences et fera
parler j'ai des fours
las connaissez pas
il semblait sincère
je l'aimais pour ça
vous
gears a toujours dérangé
eto'o rarement soins j'épousais de cas
mais dès qu'il nous tend
je ne fais jamais
il
[Musique]
marc en jeu
je voyais déjà
lannion
à
il a
[Musique]
aco
je ne savais
pas
affichant des voix
ap
rugby je le concède qu'à lui
même si j'ai cramer
que souvent ils mentent et
il se perdait dans ce qu'il raconte et
se transmettent mots quand il disait
qu'il m'aimait je suivrai
je savais faire
quant à kate j'ai trouvé des jouets
j'écris que son ex continuer de la clé
qu'est-ce qu'il que
je la découvrais
marçais
accro
l'armure dans ses bras
il a
mais bon
oh
je de ça
je le connais c'est mort
j'y vis j'y mets 2 1 d'un chien de
compagnie [ __ ] maison tu imagines tu
fais plus de familles j'étais dans toi
est dans le flou j'étais dans le drame a
surpris
elle est tout de suite venu jouer
j'étais pas la première comme avait pu
s'amuser pendant ce temps j'étais dans
fou j'étais d'enfants
ce qui m'a
et comme soi
je m'en doutais
[Musique]
hélas
waouh
[Musique]
je voyais
il
[Musique]
je ne
ça
[Musique]
il avait
il est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on était vraiment way n'a pas été chiche
west ham a été sur le public y des six
[Musique]
wasir il y avait 6
[Applaudissements]